what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
explaining the massive plot twist in
attack on Titan which led to Armin arler
- replacing bertolt hoover as the next
colossal Titan now of course this twist
is nothing new for manga readers but now
that this part of the story has aired in
the anime I can finally make a full
video on it without worrying about anime
only fans being completely shocked and
confused by what I am talking about so I
am about to explain how exactly Armin
became a Titan why he was chosen over
other potential candidates like her win'
and how becoming a Titan is likely to
affect
Armin's character in the future if you
enjoy the attack on titan content on
this channel you want to see more you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell as part of his plan to defeat Bert
olds colossal Titan Armin chose to
sacrifice himself by distracting
Berthold for long enough for Aaron to
sneak up on him and cut the nape of his
Titans neck because the colossal Titan
was emitting steam at the time Armand's
flesh was badly burnt but he chose not
to run away because he wanted to buy
more time for Eren while Berto was
focusing on Armin he did not notice that
Aaron had left his hardened Titan shell
behind and used his 3d maneuvering gear
to sneak up on the colossal Titan from
behind when he decided on this plan
Armin had already made his peace with
death he was prepared to make the
ultimate sacrifice and he only wished
that instead of him Aaron would be able
to one day see the ocean Armand's plan
ultimately succeeds because Aaron is
able to sneak up on the colossal Titan
cut the nape of its neck and rip bertolt
from the inside however although Armin
is badly injured by the steam and
although he is burnt to the point of
being unrecognizable it turns out that
he is still alive just barely at this
point
Eren Levi hanji and the others have to
make a difficult choice they know that
they can save Arman's life by injecting
him with the titan serum and turning him
into a pure Titan also known as a
mindless Titan and then having him eat
Bertolt this would turn Armin into the
colossal titan but it would also save
his life
less Levi soon realizes that commander
Erwin is still alive as well both Armin
and Erwin are on the edge of death but
the Titan serum can be used to save only
one of them as the commander of the
survey Corps and the inspirational
leader of the Scouts
Erwin is the logical choice he clearly
outranks Armin and on paper he is the
more indispensable member of the survey
corps his leadership skills are also far
superior to our means and at a difficult
time such as this great leadership
qualities are crucial but in spite of
all of these facts the scouts ultimately
decide to save Armin they inject him
with a Titan serum an Armin turns into a
mindless Titan in this form Armin eats
bertolt and upon inheriting the colossal
Titan power from bertolt Armin returns
to his normal human form only now his
body is completely healed from the
severe burns and injuries that he had
suffered at the hands of the colossal
Titan steam so why was Armin chosen
instead of Aaron why would Levi save the
life of a lower ranked soldier instead
of his own commander at first Levi is
adamant about the need to save her win
while Eren and Mikasa are determined to
save Armin this makes perfect sense
because Arman is Mika son Aaron's
childhood friend and Irwin is Levi's
friend and commander so Levi is fiercely
loyal to him however after putting aside
their own personal feelings the survey
corps members realized that they must
save the one who will help them save
humanity
they must save the one who will be the
most instrumental in their ongoing fight
against the Titans and the Titan
shifters
despite Herman's exceptional leadership
qualities and his experience as a
military commander at the end of the day
it was Armand's intelligence and
strategic brilliance that has made it
possible for the survey corps to get as
far as they did it was Armin who thought
of using a boulder to seal up trois
district it was armed and who played the
key role in figuring out the female
Titans identity it was our man who
figured out that Reiner was hiding
within a crevasse of the wall and it was
Armin who figured out how to ultimately
defeat the colossal Titan without Armand
and his strategic brilliance it is very
likely that the survey corps would have
been defeated a long time ago but
more than that throughout his entire
life Armen had a dream a vision in the
end Levi is the one to make the final
decision and he decides that it is time
for Aaron to rest because Arman
strategic genius and his lifelong dream
of learning more and seeing beyond the
walls are ultimately the things that are
likely to make the biggest difference in
the fight to save humanity
not only is arming an exceptional
military strategist but he has always
had the ability to see outside the box
to question authority and to see the
things that no one else could see in the
difficult situation that humanity finds
itself behind the walls a situation in
which they have very limited information
about their enemies and the world beyond
the walls a visionary like Arman
someone who is capable of seeing outside
the box is essential for victory levi
realizes that
Armin's questioning nature an
unconventional way of thinking could
prove to be the most important factors
in the coming war the factors that will
make the biggest difference between
victory and defeat
and this is why Levi even though he is
deeply conflicted ultimately chooses to
save Arman while allowing Herman to
finally rest in peace
it is deeply frustrating that Erlin had
to die before fulfilling his lifelong
dream of learning the truth about this
world the truth hidden in the basement
but Herman's brave sacrifice created a
new hope for Humanity and his legacy
will never be forgotten eventually our
man awakes after having dreams about
bertolt and the colossal Titan upon
waking Armin can't remember what
happened and he is confused to see
everyone's reaction to the fact that he
is still alive
Armin is shocked when he is told the
truth that he was on the brink of death
and that he was turned into a Titan and
eight bertolt in order to become the
next colossal Titan Herman is confused
that he asks why he was chosen to become
the colossal Titan instead of Commander
Erwin but Levi tells him that the final
decision was his leave I was entrusted
with the Titan serum by Erwin and Levi
chose to allow Herman to die and to save
Armin because he possesses qualities
that no one else does as I said earlier
those qualities are his strategic
brilliance and his visionary spirit his
ability to see outside the box and think
in unique way
that no one else can duplicate Armand is
overwhelmed by the responsibility of
having to bear the weight of Erin's
legacy on his shoulders
especially because Armand doesn't feel
like he possesses the kind of charisma
and leadership ability that erlin
possessed
Erwin was able to inspire and motivate
his soldiers even in the face of
impossible odds even in the face of
certain death an Armand doesn't think
that he can ever fill those shoes but
Han Jie and the others tell him that
Erwin is dead and he is alive the
decision has been made and Armand and a
handful of other members of the survey
corps who actually managed to survive
the Battle of Chicago in a district all
have to do their best to honor
Irwin's sacrifice and the sacrifice of
their other comrades they have to do
their best to continue to fight to save
humanity from the Titans now I'd like to
ask you guys to let me know what you
think did Levi make the right decision
by choosing to save arm and over
erwin do you think that Armin's unique
talents will justify Levi's decision in
the end or do you think that the
leadership of urban was irreplaceable
and no one else will be able to compare
to his charisma and force of will let me
know down in the comments personally I
think that this was one of the hardest
dilemmas in the entire series and the
fact that arm and became the colossal
Titan is one of the craziest twists in
attack on Titan I definitely think that
urban was an irreplaceable leader and
that Armand will never be able to match
Aaron's ability to make a powerful
speech to motivate his men against all
odds and to inspire hope and confidence
by the sheer strength of his will
however I do feel that arm and strategic
genius and his ability to think in
unconventional ways and see the things
that others cannot see are the most
important attributes for a member of the
Sur record to have at this point in time
no matter how great you are in inspiring
your man if you go into battle without
the proper information and without
proper strategy you are sure to lose the
survey corps members and all of humanity
behind the walls faces an enemy that is
a huge unknown although their knowledge
of mindless Titans is pretty good and
has been increasing in recent years the
knowledge that Humanity behind the walls
possesses about the Titan shifters like
Reiner and the Beast Titan is very
limited on top of that their knowledge
of the world beyond the walls is even
more limited
Armin has heard some vague
is about oceans and other geological
formations but none of them have ever
seen the outside world so none of them
have accurate knowledge of what is
happening beyond the walls in order to
deal with such a difficult situation
where you are facing a fierce enemy with
very limited information you need to
have a true visionary on your team
someone who can think critically think
outside the box and come up with
brilliant strategies that the enemy
won't be able to anticipate at the end
of the day the one who fits the
description of this visionary most
closely is Arman and for that reason I
believe that Levi made the right
decision when he chose to say Arman
instead of urban even though I know that
it was an incredibly difficult decision
that Levi never wanted to have to make
and that is how Arman became the next
colossal Titan and why he was chosen to
inherit Bertil stuck in Shafter power
instead of a win this transformation is
sure to have a massive impact on Armin's
character not only will he now inherit
some of the memories of the previous
colossal Titan holders like Bertolt and
not only will he have to live with the
guilt of having consumed it killed his
former friend bertolt but now that he is
a Titan shifter Arman will have colossal
responsibilities he will be expected to
fight and kill in the name of the survey
Corps and with the colossal Titans
massive size these fights could result
in collateral damage and deaths of
innocent people what's more as a Titan
shifter Armand will now become a target
for Reiner and the other enemy shifters
who will be determined to get the
colossal Titan power back finally as one
of humanity's greatest weapons Armand
will now have to perform exceptionally
in battle even though direct combat was
never one of his strong suits everyone
will be counting on Armin and that is a
massive responsibility to bear
especially knowing that he was saved
instead of commander owynn whatever
happens these recent events in the
attack on titan story are sure to have a
massive impact on armin as a character
feel free to give me your take about
this whole massive plot twist down below
and don't forget to follow me on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar to stay
up-to-date with all the latest attack on
titan news and updates if you enjoyed
this video you can leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification Val
a huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work
and when I especially thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
keelon and chubs is the man and another
huge thank you to our the one to your
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace Maddie Mac
James a lowland Adam in grata and Ahmad
and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to baby ray the first ever
disciple of Lord to ego himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]